hello and welcome to your fifth WX
Python tutorial in the last tutorial we
covered adding another button and then
also the concept of panels so if you
don't recall where we left off I'll
bring up the example that we left off on
so we had a couple of buttons the Edit
buttons is doing nothing for us we have
a file and exit and then we have we made
a panel that was just a basic text box
so now what I'd like to do in this
tutorial is cover some more user input
and then have me some dynamic stuff
based on that user input so what I'm
going to do is let's put this up a
little bit and right below the
definition of our window information
we're going to start adding in this
stuff so what we're going to say like
let's say we want to have just a yes or
no box pop-up for these people and we
want to log whether they say yes or no
so a simple yes/no is is following so
I'm going to say yes no box equals you
need to do W X dot message dialog it's
going to have no parent so none and then
in the second parameter you say what you
want the message to say in this case
we're going to have it asked do you
enjoy W X Python in the next parameter
you give the title of that little box
window thing and so that's just going to
be question and then in the final
parameter you specify what kind of
message dialog it is and in this case
it's going to be a yes/no dialog that
just comes with W X Python so it knows
like what kind of button to put at the
bottom of it so that's our yes/no box
now we're going to say yes no answer is
we want to store whatever they say
so yes no answer is going to be equal to
yes no box dot show modal and so
basically that's just going to say like
what what was the answer here like
that's the modal so it's going to store
in this yes/no answer variable whether
or not or what the answer was and then
finally whenever they finish this the
next step is just going to be check or
yes/no box die destroy we're gonna just
annihilate it so now what it's going to
do is we're not doing anything with it
yet but if they it we are going to store
whatever they answer here so we'll save
that we'll run it and hopefully we can
screw anything up and so yeah you see
here this little window comes up and
it's a question do you enjoy WX pine and
of course we do so I hit yes and then
pops up our epic window so obviously
pretty basic stuff so far nothing really
changed but we did at least store that
and we got that message pop up so pretty
cool but let's make it even cooler let's
say before this happens let's do another
event and let's say we want it to pick
up your name
so we'll do we'll call this name box
equals WX text entry dialog again
there's no parent to this and we're
going to have it ask what is your name
for the second parameter that's what
like the question is going to be then
you've got the title kind of like the
other one was and the title that this is
going to be welcome and then finally the
fourth parameter is kind of like an HTML
you've got default text in a text box so
you can leave it blank or you can say
like I'm just going to put name in there
and so whenever the user goes there like
it's kind of like what's already in the
box and it can help guide people as to
what to type even though it says like
what is your name it can help them you
know type it in
so then when someone enters their name
that box is going to have an OK or a
cancel and so if they hit cancel then we
don't really want to do anything but if
they hit ok then we want to store the
value that they put in here so to do
that we'll just have a simple if
statement and we'll say if name box dot
show modal as in if the mode that the
user picks based on these buttons is a
WX period ID okay is in if the mode that
shows is an OK button then what we want
to do is let's go ahead and store that
user name in the variable user name and
what we're going to store there is going
to be the value and the way you do that
is just name box not get value so we
want to pull whatever information that
they put in that little box we want to
pull that storing user name so with that
let's save that and we'll run it and
we'll see the first message that pops up
what's your name and we'll put my name
in there for Harrison of course I like
WX Python and then here's our window
again that we've been working on so
let's exit this and so let's make it a
little bit more dynamic let's make this
program a bit friendlier so with that
user name we can come down here and we
can do self dot set title right now just
as welcome but let's have it say welcome
space plus username so now it'll like
actually call you by your name so what
we'll do now we'll save that we'll run
it and now it says what is your name our
name my name is Harrison of course I
enjoy Python and now the window says
welcome Harrison well that's a lot more
friendly I enjoy the program more
already so let's hit exit and now that
we've done this like right we've given
this little entry a name box entry some
a little bit of dynamics so that leaves
this yes/no button we're not actually
doing anything with this button right
we've got the answer the yes/no answer
we've gotten rid of it so we do have
already have it stored in a variable
we're not actually doing anything with
that variable so let's do something with
that variable I think what we should do
is let's put down here right before we
call the username let's do a quick
little check and let's say let's do if
yes/no answer equals W X ID no so if
that answer is equal to the no button
then let's redefine username to be a
little more applicable towards our user
and we'll just change their name to
loser so now when we save this and run
it up pops name what's your name my name
is Harrison do I enjoy Python let's say
I am a loser and I hit no now our window
says welcome loser but now let's say I'm
back to regular me and I say my name is
Harrison and of course I enjoy wx--
Python now the window is more friendly
to me it says welcome Harrison well exit
that so those are the basics of text
input button input and then also making
your program a bit more dynamic based on
the users input obviously will be
getting way more into depth than that
but those are the basics so as always
thank you for watching if you enjoy
please do subscribe and until next time